In the last example
of the previous clip,
we have observed that the
initial state of where
the Markov chain starts can
matter, and that in some cases,
the influence of
the initial state
never vanishes in the long run.
So when we wanted to calculate
the probability of ending up
in state one, knowing that
you started in state one,
give you that probability, and
if you started in state three,
you had another long
term probability.
And in case you were
started in state two,
then you were equally likely
to end up being in state one
or in state three.
We have said that this
was due to the fact
that some states
are not accessible
from some other states.
Our goal here is to make
such a statement more
precise and formal.
In order to do so, we will
classify the states of a Markov
chain in a transition diagram
into two types, recurrent
and transient.
A state is said to be
recurrent if starting
from that state, no
matter where you go,
there is always a
path to come back.
A state is said to be transient
if it is not recurrent.
It means that starting
from that state,
there is at least one
place where you can go,
and then there will be
no paths back to it.
For example, starting from state
eight, no matter where you go,
there is always a
path back to eight.
So eight will be said
to be a recurrent state.
For the same reason,
seven will also
be a recurrent state,
as well as six.
Now, what about five?
From five, the only
state where you can go to
is five itself, so five
is also a recurrent state.
Let us look now at a
state like state four.
From four, there
is the possibility
of a path going
through two, then one,
and then going to
five, from which
there is no path back to four.
So four cannot be
a recurrent state.
It is then called
a transient state.
For the same reason,
starting from three,
there is the possibility that
after doing many transitions
around here, eventually, you
will end up being in either two
and then go to six, or you
will eventually be in one
and then go to five.
And from five or from six, there
will be no path back to three,
so three is also
a transient state.
And it is clear that
for the same reason,
one will be a transient
state, and two will also
be a transient state.
Now, if a state is transient,
like three, four, one, or two,
it means that it will be visited
only a finite number of times.
And in the long
run, the probability
of being in a transient
state will converge to zero.
The recurrent states
of a Markov chain
can be grouped in
different classes.
Here, in this example,
we have two such classes.
Here, this is one class, and
here you have another class.
What is so special
about these classes?
Well, within one class,
for example, in this class,
all recurrent states
have a way to communicate
between each other, but
there is no communication
between recurrent states
of different classes.
From that recurrent
state here, you
have no communication with
that recurrent state here.
No communication in
the sense that there
is no path joining that
state to that state
or that state to that state.
The existence of more than
one class of recurrent states,
like in this example,
in a Markov chain,
will be the telling
sign that initial states
will matter in that chain.
It's pretty clear here that
if your Markov chain starts
in state five, you will never
end up in state six, seven,
or eight, and if you
start in one of the states
six, seven, eight, you will
never end up in state five.
So depending on
where you started,
the long range probability of
being eventually in state six
will not be the same.